un millón de muertes por una pandemia
que no se dé en américa latina la región
alcanzó un récord de fallecimientos en
medio de una delicada situación
sanitaria argentina es uno de los países
más afectados y tras registrar recortes
de casos y muertes diarias esta semana
inició un confinamiento de nueve días
como el inicio de la pandemia sobre los
trabajadores esenciales pueden circular
una medida que divide opiniones y
retroceder un año realmente y peor
porque la gente está
peor económicamente están mal de ánimo
o sea todo para atrás a mí me parece muy
bien porque si lo podemos controlar
porque si no no sólo controlar el virus
de ninguna manera y tendría que ser más
de 9 10
para mí unos 15 días estaría bueno una
situación crítica que también registra
colombia país que además atraviesa una
crisis social por las protestas que ya
llevan más de tres semanas para mejorar
el panorama sanitario la vacunación es
clave y en esta región avanza muy
lentamente aunque empieza a mostrar
algunos efectos positivos como en méxico
que ha logrado llevar las muertes por
kobe 19 a sus cifras más bajas en un año
esto trae alivio a los cementerios en
este mes de mayo por ejemplo ha
disminuido en pues en gran cantidad del
número de de innovaciones y de
incineraciones que ahorita absorbe está
todo tranquilo porque vienen espaciados
ya no vienen tan continuos al ser a cada
media hora una situación similar a la de
brasil que ha logrado reducir las
muertes diarias aun así los
especialistas advierten sobre una
posible tercera ola debido al aumento de
las transmisiones en las últimas semanas
y luego de que se detectaran los
primeros casos de la variante india en
el país